so here's what's happening show girls
please stop talking please stop talking
right now cuz you know what no it's
happening
yep you heard that right Whoopi Goldberg
just told Meghan McCain to lock it up
live on the view I want hard to shout
okay that's I'm okay with that
things got heated on Monday's episode of
the daily talk show while the ladies
discussed politics of course including
the articles of impeachment brought
against President Donald Trump will be
felt Meghan was talking over the other
women to make her voice heard it said we
had ad stuff as always me and a bad kid
Megan was chiming in to explain that
while the president's ethics may have
been questionable impeachment could be a
disaster my job here is not to litigate
the ethics of it I'm an ABC political
analyst along with being a via co-host
my job is to analyze the politics of it
and I'm telling you while Whoopi leans
to the left Megan is the daughter of the
late US Senator John McCain and comes
from a conservative Republican
background you are with what you're
doing no I'm not sure for us we're not
doing anything how about this former FBI
we'll be right back after the argument
erupted the show went straight to
commercial break and when they returned
there was no mention of the previous
disagreement it's just really
unpredictable
then some days are really smooth and
some days are Jeanine Pirro
it just depends on what the day is I
mean I think that's why people like the
show is they know it's not scripted and
they know it's not we're not being phony
and I'm not trying to placate to an
audience and we're also not you know
there's I've watched other shows that we
compete with and we don't shy away from
controversy and really hard topics but
Megan did not look happy and she did not
speak
this is a season for the Hallmark
Channel to show 10,000 Christmas movies
now while it might have been
uncomfortable to watch this is just
another day at the office for the view
ladies they told ET earlier this year
they're able to shake off the fights and
heated moments after the cameras stopped
rolling are you able to shake it off
after after show yeah I mean we all have
lives
yeah ps3 baby is gonna we all have other
projects and things going on it I
actually forget about it other people
remind me of fights I'm like out you
remember that one happening sure though
you know I let it roll off pretty easy
when you come back season after season
what is your thought process going into
keeping the table peaceful making marks
you know I don't give that any thought
at all
no because chill I am chill this is
actually Who I am I don't I don't I try
not to stress out I try not to and I
deal with stuff as it happens you
actually get along the best because we
always want to watch news after and
still talk about yeah that's true I
think we're always ready these are
really tumultuous times and I think
that's why you see the tumult at the
table because we're talking about the
stuff that everyone is talking about and
these aren't the times to sort of dance
around the issues we've got to hit them
head-on
[Music]